self-censorship is neither inherently
bad nor is it inherently good and one of
the things that I've been thinking about
recently is is what Adam Smith had to
tell us about this Adam Smith is an 18th
century moral philosopher most people
know him for the wealth of nations but I
think that his work from the Theory of
Moral Sentiments is really helpful in
this and helping us to figure out when
it is appropriate and when it is not
appropriate to engage in self-censorship
think for example of you're in a live
exchange with a conversation partner
there's you're in front of an audience
and your conversation partner starts
acting like an arrogant jerk right what
do you do right we our first impulse
might be to sort of mirror that behavior
to to kind of jump in and start being an
arrogant jerk back right but if we're um
you know kind of wise to the ways of the
world you know we tend to say maybe
that's not the right thing to do
right and what we're doing here is we're
engaging what Smith called the impartial
spectator and we start to view our own
conduct through not through our own eyes
which is tends to be partial we tend to
be too forgiving of ourselves but
through the eyes of somebody else and
the really wise scholar is not going to
or the really wise person in this
conversation is not going to just look
at our conduct from the vantage point of
our conversation partner who's being
such an arrogant jerk we're going to be
looking at our conduct from the
standpoint of the audience if it's in an
academic setting it would be that
general academic audience and we would
imagine ourselves switching places with
them right and then looking at our
prospective conduct kind of doing the
gut check is my is what I'm about to say
appropriate is it proper is it in
alignment with what's expected of me as
a student or as a scholar and that helps
us by switching by imagining that we're
switching places that helps us to kind
of find the right thing to do right
which is to say want to continue to
in alignment with what's expected within
the general academic public but also it
helps us to muster up the restraint to
dampen down our emotions and this is
what Smith called self command right so
those are that's that's one thing that
we need to recognize is that in that
moment we are engaging in a form of
self-censorship there where we're
censoring or dampening down what would
have been our immediate response that's
a good thing this is really important I
mean Smith's entire theory of how we are
able to live in a world where we are
governed by moral principles depends on
us being being able to align our conduct
with what's expected in society
generally so this is really really
important but let's imagine a different
scenario right where you're again in an
exchange with a fellow scholar or a
classmate and there are onlookers right
and this time you're getting challenged
in ways that are really confrontational
not just by your conversation partner
but by the the whole audience the whole
classroom perhaps the Twittersphere is
lighting up with condemnation of you and
your position right what do you do in
that case right and that's a time where
again Smith understood that the clamor
he called it the clamor and vehement
of public opinion may be so strong that
you start to you know say even the
seasoned scholar might say you know I I
want to take a pause here because I'm
I'm worried that my impartial spectator
may be off off-kilter a little bit right
so I'm gonna pause I'm gonna think
really hard about what's being said
there right but if after considering it
carefully if if I really am aiming at
truth seeking in this case if I'm doing
if I'm really aiming at doing that which
is praiseworthy and not simply chasing
praise itself then if I'm going to then
make my argument at that point after
I've had that sort of thoughtful
deliberation then it's that it's this
then it's something that the impartial
spectator will
approve of even if there's a lot of
clamor and vehement sfrom the crowd I
can trust that impartial judge right
who's looking at my behavior and saying
no you were sincerely aiming at truth
you think that you're advancing the
conversation in a way that is going to
expand knowledge and you're doing it in
a way that's in in in keeping with
civility then you have pleased me says
the impartial spectator but here's the
thing you don't just arrive on to the
stage of academic discourse or the arena
of public discourse fully formed in this
way it takes a lot of practice to get
there and Smith called this the and gate
by engaging in the bustle of the
business of the world we acquire that
self command that we need to adhere to
what is proper to be sure to do whatever
is possible to and to do that which is
praiseworthy and not simply chasing
praise and so that to me suggests that
we need to be really thoughtful about
developing in our students with our
colleagues in ourselves that sense of
self command that allows us to take a
breath right really assess whether or
not what we're about to say is in
alignment with or in in opposition to
what would be expected of any civil
scholar right who's out there in the
world whether it's a student or whether
it's a professor but then when we decide
that no this is what we should be doing
because I am sincerely moving forward
with an argument that I believe is going
to expand truth from there we need to
summon that courage to do the right
thing which in that case would be to
speak up and that takes reps it's like
it's like an athlete right that it an
accomplished athlete drills so many
times they get that sort of muscle
memory where when it
it's really difficult to do something in
the moment of the big game day it feels
actually pretty easy to do because
they've done it so many times before and
so similarly we need to become practiced
in exercising this the skill of
switching places and really assessing
our conduct from the vantage point
sometimes of the general public but also
sometimes from that that impartial
well-informed judge that is going to
give us an honest assessment of our
conduct despite what the clamor and
vehemence of the crowd might say
[Music]
you